LAYER UP TO SURVIVE THESE FRIGID
CONDITIONS.
>> Bret: IN WHATEVER HAPPENED TO
SEGUEMENT, THE LITTLE CUBAN BOY
HE IS A GROWN MAN.
MANY REMEMBER HIM AS A SYMBOL OF
A FLIGHTENED LITTLE BOY.
I COVERED IT BACK THEN.
TONIGHT STEVE HAS THE STORY FROM
>> I WAS LOOKING AT THE INNER
TUBE.
I SEEN MY COUSIN PULLING IN THE
FISH, I SEEN A HAND MOVE ON THAT
PERISHING WITH 10 OTHERS.
MIAMI RELATIVES INCLUDING TWO
GREAT UNCLES REFUSED TO SEND HIM
BACK TO THE DICTATORSHIP HIS
MOTHER DIED TRYING TO ESCAPE.
>> THE ULTIMATE SACRIFICE OF THE
MOTHER WHO WANTED FREEDOM FOR
>> THE CUSTODY BATTLE
ELECTRIFIED CUBANS ON BOTH
SIDES.
EKE
EK
IN LITTLE HAVANA
AROUND-THE-CLOCK VIGIL WERE HELD
AROUND THE FAMILY HOME.
THE STALEMATE INVOLVING THIS
LITTLE BOY COULD THROW NEW
IMMIGRATION TALKS INTO JEOPARDY.
>> IN CUBA, FIDEL CASTRO LED
DAILY PROTESTS DEMANDING THE
BOY'S RETURN TO HIS FATHER.
THE INTERNATIONAL DRAMA DRAGGED
ON FOR 7 MONTHS.
UNTIL THE CLINTON ADMINISTRATION
SENT IMMIGRATION AGENCY ARMED
FOR BATTLE INTO THE HOME.
THE FISHERMAN WHO SAVED THE BOY
HAD HIM SNATCHED FROM HIS ARMS.
ELIAN'S FATHER, ELIAN JOINED THE
YOUNG COMMUNIST UNION AND BECAME
AN ENGINEER.
18 YEARS LATER FIDEL CASTRO IS
GONE FROM THE SCENE.